[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité dans les
Yvelines il y aura-t-il l'ouverture
d'une commission d'enquête pour le jeûne
Nicolas à Poissy c'est en tout cas ce
que propose la députée les républicains
des Alpes-Maritimes Christelle d'interny
pour mettre en lumière toutes les
circonstances du drame qui ont poussé au
suicide de l'adolescence scolarisé à
Poissy le 5 septembre dernier après
plusieurs autres villes françaises
Poissy n'a pas été épargné par la
multiplication des fausses alertes à la
bombe qui touchent des établissements
scolaires depuis lundi mardi c'est le
lycée Charles de Gaulle qui a été pris
pour cible aux alentours de 14h les 113
élèves ont été évacués de leur
établissement rapidement un lourd
dispositif policier a été mis en place
pour évacuer et sécuriser les lieux les
cours ont finalement repris en fin
d'après-midi une fois le doute levé
Guyancourt solidaire avec le Maroc et la
Libye François Morton le maire de la
commune a annoncé proposé au prochain
conseil municipal que soit versé à la
Fondation de France ainsi que 3000 euros
à la Croix-Rouge française ces sommes
serviront à venir en aide aux victimes
on termine par du golf les Green du Golf
National de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
sont prêts pour accueillir l'Open de
France de golf 2023 la compétition
débute ce jeudi 21 septembre et se
terminera ce dimanche plusieurs favoris
se dégagent pour ce rendez-vous
l'Américain Billy yorkshell et surtout
le jeune prodige sud-coré un Tom Kim du
côté des Français livelinois Antoine
rosener sera aussi de la partie